INSTRUCTOR: Hi there,
2,100 students.
We're going to talk about
input validation today.
So our objectives are to
understand and apply the two
ways in this class,
I should say,
that we will
validate user input.
There's a variety
of ways to do so,
but as we're focusing on
these core Python objectives
in this class, we're going
to look at try and accept
and how we can use
while loops generally
with the help of some
if-statements to validate user
input.
Validating user input goes
directly along with the idea
of data quality
that we are asked
if we're asking our users to
input, say some sort of form
where they're filling
out their information
and we want to
validate that they
enter a valid, a valid email
address, or a valid phone
number, or what have
you, that then we
can enter that
data from that form
that we're receiving through our
Python script into a database.
And it can be data quality,
it can have good data quality
characteristics.
So Python and databases
go hand in hand
and doing things like this.
So as a reminder, while loops
right set of instructions
happen over and
over and over again
until some condition is met.
Now, we can validate
with while loops,
we can say you must enter
something that starts with an A,
or you must have at least
a five character password,
or what have you.
So while loops just can
enforce that repetition.
And try and accept
handles errors.
So we're going to talk
about both of those today.
So try and accept allows
you to try something
if there's something
that you try
doesn't work more than likely
because there is an error rather
than crash, Python does
whatever you tell it to do
in the case of an exception.
So this is mainly used to
verify the kind of data
from the input is valid.
So for example, if we ask our
users to enter an integer,
we then convert that entry into
an integer and the conversion
fails.
Then instead of my
program just crashing,
we can actually use
a try and accept
and we can actually
output something
to the user like, wrong data
type, enter something different.
So with while loops,
we're generally
focused on the content
of my user's input.
And with try and
accept, we're generally
focused on the type
of data being entered.
So again, try and accept
validates the type of user input
without the program
crashing, while loop
will validate the content
of the user's input.
So let's jump into our
examples for today.
Here, under question number one,
we're going to use a while loop.
We're going to ask the user to
input a 5 character string that
starts with the letter
A if the user inputs
a string of the wrong length,
tell them of their error
and insist that they input
a correct length string.
If the user inputs a string
that does not start with an A,
tell them of their error.
The string is 5
characters long and does
start with an A output
for the user their string
and congratulate them.
All right, so I'm going to
use what we just talked about
in our while discussion.
We're going to say good
input is equal to 0.
This is going to be my marker
variable here for this program.
Again, my marker
variable is what
begin-- is basically
what I'm going
to use as my conditional
statement within my while loop.
Before I add my
while loop in, let's
just talk about the core
part of this program.
So let's get our base
program running then we'll
add in the while loop.
When I talk about
a base program,
I mean the program
that's actually
has the logic built into it,
the if statements, the input,
then we'll just add a
while loop at the end.
So let's ask my user--
I'm going to say user
string is equal to input,
so I'm going to validate
that it's 5 characters
and starts with an A.
So I'm going to say,
let's be good prompt,
write a good prompt here.
I'll say, please
enter a five character
string that starts with an A.
So let's go ahead and do that.
Then I'm going to run it
and make sure that works.
I'll say Apple.
OK, perfect.
Nothing else runs.
I haven't determined
if they actually
entered a five character
string that starts with an A,
but my user input is working.
So let's first off,
if the user inputs
a string of the wrong length,
tell them of their error
and insist that they input
a correct length string.
So I'm going to say if they
enter an incorrect length
string.
Now, there's a variety of ways
you can write this program.
This is just one way.
I'm going to say
if the-- and then
I'm going to use the length
command, which determines
the length of my user string.
So I'll say if the
length of my user string
is not equal to five.
So if they enter an
incorrect string length,
again, my length command
goes into the user string
and says and counts the
number of characters.
If it is not equal to five.
So if this is true,
right not equal to five,
then I'll say print invalid
input was not long enough.
So if that is true,
then the input
was not long enough,
which is right.
And then it says that they
input a correct length string.
All right.
If the user inputs a string
that does not start with an A,
tell them of their error.
So if this is not true--
or sorry if this
is true, then we
know that they did not enter
a correct length string.
If that is not true, then they
did enter a correct length
string.
And I want to determine
in my else block,
I'm going to embed
an if and I'm going
to say let's determine that
what they did enter actually
started with an A. So I'm going
to say if the user string--
and this is
something that we are
going to cover more in just
a bit but let's talk about it
right now.
I'll say, if the user
string, I want to say,
does it start with an A--
does it start with an A?
And we are going to utilize
indexes, which is basically
I can pinpoint a character
within my string variable.
And I want to say that is the
first value of the user string,
does it start with an A?
And I can pinpoint that first
value by utilizing indexes.
Indexes come directly
after my variable's name
in brackets and indexes start--
Python starts counting at 0.
So if I want to look at user
string is equal to Apple.
A would be 0.
The first P would be one.
The second P would be two.
So indexes again, Python
starts counting at 0.
We'll get more into this,
this is just an introduction,
but I want to say if the first
value of that user string.
Again, Python starts
counting at 0.
So we say if user string index
value 0 is equal-equal to A.
So if they entered
the correct length
string and the first
value of their user string
is equal to a then I'll print.
Thank you for entering
a correct length
string that starts with
an A. And then I will--
that's correct.
They have correctly entered
a five character string
that starts with the letter A.
Else I will print, make sure
your five character string
starts with an A. OK, perfect.
So now once I run this,
let's try it out here.
Please enter a five
character string
that starts with an A. Let's
enter a way too long character
string and I'll hit Enter.
It says invalid input.
Input was not long enough.
That's not actually true.
Let's just say input was
not the correct length.
OK because actually
it was too long.
All right, so let's
change that up now.
Let's type in
something too long.
It says invalid input was not
the correct length, perfect.
Now, let's enter
five characters that
does not start with the
letter A. I'll hit Enter.
It says make sure your five
character string starts
with an A. So it does.
It came here the if
block was not true.
So my else block ran.
This if was not true so my else
block ran and it output that
to me.
Now, let's enter
a five character
string that starts
with the letter A.
And my if block is not true.
So my else block runs,
this if was true.
So then it prints, thank you
for entering a correct length
string that starts
with an A. All right.
Awesome.
Now, I want to start with
an A and I want to output
to them their output your.
So once they-- sorry, once they
enter a correct length string,
then what starts
with the letter A,
I want to output to
them their string.
So thank you for entering
your correct length string
that starts with the
letter A. Entered.
And then I will add in here the
value from the variable user
string.
I'm going to then tell it
that I'm using f strings.
All right.
So now when I run this, I
will say Apple and perfect.
Thank you for entering
the correct length
string that starts with
an A. You entered Apple.
Now, I want to do this,
but I want to continue.
I'm going to add in
a while loop here,
so I want to continue asking
them to enter a correct length
string starts with the letter A.
So I'll say while good input is
equal-equal to 0.
Again, I have my
colon, then everything
indented and beneath this.
I want this to continue running
over and over and over again.
So let's play this now.
Let's enter Apple and
it says, Thank you
for entering a correct length
string that starts with an A,
you entered Apple.
Well, then it asks me again.
So I forgot to enter.
I forgot to add something
here to actually make
me leave the while loop.
So let's say here that once
they enter a correct length
string that starts with the
letter A. So in my nested
if block, I'm going to then
say good input equal to 1
and I'll leave the loop.
All right, so now
let's run this again.
Please enter a
correct length string
that starts with the letter A.
Let's enter something too long.
Perfect, not the correct length.
Let's enter five
characters but it
doesn't start with the letter.
All right, perfect.
Now, let's enter Apple.
It says, thank you for
entering the correct length
string that starts with
an A, you entered Apple.
All right, perfect.
So there is that program
number one up there for us now,
same as program number one.
But tell the user
how many times it
took them to enter
a five character
string that starts with an A.
So I'm going to come up here.
I'm going to copy this
program down again.
And this time, I want to
use my counter variables
and I want to tell them how
many times it took them to guess
the correct length string.
So I'm going to elicit a
counter variables help here
and I'll say counter
is equal to 0.
And then I want to every
time through the loop,
I want to increase
the counter variable.
So I want to say, all
right, after I ask my user,
I want to increase
counter by one,
so increase my counter by one.
So again, every time that
I ask my user to input,
the next thing it's going to do
is increase the counter by one.
And then I use if my
else my if and my else.
All right, so now
let's run this.
I'll say Apple.
I hit Enter.
Thank you for entering
correct length string.
Awesome.
And-- but I need to tell
them how many times it
took them to enter a valid
five character string that
starts with an A. So I
need to tell them that once
they enter a five character
string that starts with an A,
so down here in my nested if.
I'm going to say you
entered user string.
It took you-- and then
I'll tell it, it took you--
enter my curly brackets,
curly braces, counter times.
So I'm going to enter the
value from the variable counter
there on my correct
print statement.
So now I'll run this.
Please enter a five
character string
that starts with the letter A,
I do something way too long.
So I guess one time.
I'm going to guess
a second time.
I'm going to guess a third time.
Then finally on the last one,
I'm going to guess correctly.
So it took me four times to
guess the correct length string
or to get to input a 5
character string that
starts with the letter
A. So you can see here
that as you're entering
your A number, that
could be a check that there's
a program behind whatever
interface you're working
with that says, all right
we must check that
there a number starts
with an A. Same thing that
we just did right here.
All right.
On program number 3, we're
going to ask the user
to input an integer.
If they enter an integer,
congratulate them
on knowing what an integer is.
Otherwise, tell
them of their error.
The program should not crash.
All right, so let's say
x is equal to input.
Please enter an integer.
So I just want my user
to enter an integer.
Then I want to say, x is
equal to integer form of x.
So I'm going to convert
their entry to an integer.
Now remember, input is always
interpreted as a string,
so we've got to convert
it to be an integer.
Now, when I run this-- and I and
then let's say, let's print x.
So when I run this.
Let's say I actually
entered an integer 7
and I hit Enter, seven
outputs to me, which is great.
Now, what if I actually
type out the word 7, right.
I hit Enter and I get
a value error invalid
literal for int with base 10 7.
What this means is
that it's saying
I can't convert your entry to
be an integer because it's not
an integer.
So my program crashed.
My program crashed.
This is an error.
So my program just ends.
My user is like, I have
no idea what happened.
Some sort of error popped up.
Maybe nothing popped up.
So what we're going
to do is we're
going to be good programmers and
we're going to after we ask them
to enter their input,
then I'm going to say,
I'm going to try and convert
their entry to be an integer.
If that does not work,
so if there is an error,
this will run, and
I'm going to say,
Print ugh that was
not an integer.
All right.
Up here in my try block
instead of just printing x,
I'm going to say that was,
print that was an integer.
Good job.
So I'm going to ask my user
to please enter an integer.
Then my try block
will run and it's
going to first say,
all right, let's try
and convert their
entry to be an integer.
If this fails, then nothing
else in my try block will run
and my except block
will run instead.
If this actually works,
then just my print
within my try block will
run and we're good to go.
All right.
So let's press Play here.
Please enter an integer.
I say 7, I hit Enter.
It says that was an integer.
Good job.
My program is over.
Just my try block ran
Now, let's try it again.
And I'm going to type
out the word seven.
I'll hit Enter.
It says Ugh, that
was not an integer.
So it tried to
convert their value,
their entry to be an integer.
That did not work.
So then it ran my except
block and it said,
Ugh, That was not an integer.
And it printed that out to me.
But at least then I can
communicate with my user.
So try and accept focuses
on the type of data
that we're entering.
Is it an integer, is it
a float, what have you?
And then while loops really
focus on the content of it,
of my user's input.
All right, so there you have it.
Here's three programs
validating user input.
We'll continue to
work with this,
but I hope that this was
helpful to work through today.
Thanks, everybody.
Take care.